Breaking up the Yemeni state is better than
fighting to keep it together, right?
It’s an appealing thought and not unprecedented.
Yemen used to be two countries—the North
and South united in 1990.
Southerners started and lost a civil war in
1994, and
a secessionist movement re-emerged in 2007-2008.
And the frontline of today’s war is largely
along the old North-South border.
Re-dividing Yemen won’t bring peace.
Or remove Iran’s and al Qaeda’s footprints.
In the north, there will be a contest between
the former Yemeni president Ali Abdullah Saleh,
and the Iranian-backed al Houthi movement.
Regardless of who wins, the al Houthis will
keep a statelet in the north, preserving Iran’s
influence.
Who provides much-needed financial support
to the north remains an open question.
Saudi Arabia won’t and Iran can’t.
The other half of the country—the South—is
far from stable.
An ongoing power contest among various factions,
including the internationally recognized Yemeni
government, will distract from any concerted
effort against al Qaeda.
Instead of solving Yemen, breaking up the
state just replicates the problems.
What do you think the future of Yemen looks like?
Let us know in your comments.
Also let us know what other topics you want our scholars to cover in 60 Seconds,
and be sure to like and subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.